supporte plus en politique
beaucoup développé d'ailleurs par par
certain nombre de partisans emmanuel
macron cette idée de deux oui mais
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait d'autres
qu'est ce que vous auriez faire sauriez
pas fait mieux à leur place le contester
commande
vous à lens après les errances en
l'occurrence sur la question de
l'énergie aie sur la question du
nucléaire oui les républicains sont la
seule formation politique depuis 20 ans
30 ans n'ont jamais lâché en matant du
cap nous ne sommes pas tout à fait la
joie des républicains mais choqué les
communistes aussi qu'on était assez
courageux
en la matière on n'a pas cédé au
politiquement ou politiquement correct
et alors si on prend aussi on prend les
fesses et c'est très clair dans les
présidents de la république de notre
famille politique nicolas sarkozy est
quand même celui qui a lancé les ep r on
a voté une loi pour lancer les opm il a
assumé le lancement du chantier de
flamanville c'était c'était courageux il
y avait des manifestations des dizaines
de milliers manifestants beaucoup
d'associations écologistes qui étaient
contre il l'a fait donc non tout n'est
pas pareil et ceux qui ont pris des
mauvaises décisions qui font que la
france aujourd'hui a perdu son
indépendance
et bien d'autres doivent doivent en
assumer les conséquences et
responsabilité c'est inhérent aux
principes